ok so now we're going to talk about
another strategy that we're going to use
in helping you
of course you started there you're going
to start the eating plan but there's
something you have to realize if you're
trying to lose weight there are other
things that are going to slow you down
and act as barriers and we must address
them so whichever one you have you're
going to watch that specific video so we
can fix it
so what will stop you from losing weight
that goes beyond the eating plan is the
sleep if you're not sleeping you're not
going to lose weight it's not going to
happen because you burn all the fat when
you're sleeping and then when you watch
that video we're going to talk about the
underlying causes of lack of sleep it
could be the adrenal gland it could be
sleep apnea which you're missing certain
nutrients that the swelling is going on
your nose that you can't breathe that
night there's mineral deficiencies
there's all sorts of causes to sleep but
that's one big barrier also digestion if
your digestion is off if you have a
constipation if you get bloating if you
feel very full all the time or you have
a swollen stomach we have to fix that
because it's not going you're not going
to lose weight it's going to also
interfere your ability to sleep so
digestion is very important to use that
as an indicator that know that it's
working
energy level you think you're really
going to lose weight if you're tired and
you're fatigued now a lot of energy
problems come from sleep issues but it
can also come from a thyroid issue it
can come from anemia you don't have
enough iron in your blood it can come
from a lot of different sources so in
the video and energy if you have fatigue
watch that one you will actually address
that menstrual cycle if your menstrual
cycle is off you're gonna have a hard
time losing weight why because that
means your estrogen off and estrogen
makes fat so we want that estrogen to be
at the right level so it doesn't
interfere with the thyroid and it does
interfere with just making fat generally
speaking so we want that menstrual cycle
to be very smooth we want the menopausal
symptoms like the hot flashes to be
completely gone again you're having
night sweats and hot flashes all night
long
it's
if you're asleep you're not gonna lose
weight these are just barriers cravings
one way I know that you're burning fat
is you crave nothing and you're not so
hungry all the time if you're craving
sweets you're burning sugar that's all
that means
so we must fix the cravings and we're
gonna do it within the program
inflammation that's another barrier that
means that your adrenals aren't strong
enough and you have it's it's almost
equivalent to having way too many
applications on your desktop computer
and it's running and it's sucking energy
from the body and it's making you your
metabolism not work as is good because
it draws power from the adrenal glands
okay so we want the adrenal glands to be
chilled out and that brings us to the
next thing of stress if the body is
stuck in stress mode and it can't relax
and you're trying to sleep and it
doesn't let you and your excessive
thinking and all these other things that
means the adrenal glands are overloaded
and you have too much body stress we
must eliminate that to remove these
barriers to be able to lose the weight
again a lot of people focus on diet and
exercise they don't go beyond that to
look at the whole picture of the whole
body and to get the person truly healthy
I would tell you that if you didn't have
any of these issues you'd be very
healthy these are good indicators of
levels of health okay so to be able to
get we need to go we're going to handle
these and the way it's going to make it
easy for you to lose weight especially
long term